et on ouvre la page politique en france
à présent avec ces mesures que devrait
annoncer jean castex face à la hausse
des tarifs de l'énergie il devrait
également annoncer une revalorisation
des apl ou du smic et des annonces qui
interviennent la veille des
traditionnels aux du 1er octobre vont
parler ce matin avec nicolas vidal c
l'édito politique de la matinale
[Musique]
bonjour nicolas bonjour ravi de vous
avoir dans la matinale de rtl france
comme tous les jeudis alors comme chaque
année le 1er octobre évidemment il y à
ces changements dans la vie des français
avec des revalorisations mais aussi des
augmentations qui impacte évidemment
bourdonnement parfois la vie des
français vous l'avez dit magali ce matin
je suis impatient que veut donner la
recette de la sauce à laquelle nous
allons être mangés dès demain et vous
allez voir c'est pas triste alors prenez
un stylo charge amis et fait deux
colonnes avec d'un côté les pseudos
bonus sociaux et de la détresse de
mauvaises nouvelles étaient mauvaises
nouvelles qui vont alourdir le quotidien
déjà difficile 2 millions de français
dans la première colonne on va noter les
hausses concédé à nous pauvres français
moyen les manants les gueux descendance
qui ne sont rien et qui constituent les
peuples à de très éloigné du
périphérique parisien dans cette
première colonne nous pourrons noter
deux choses n'hésitez pas à écrire au
camp dans cette colonne franchement y'a
pas grand chose d'une phare la
revalorisation générale des appels les
allocations personnalisées logements qui
vont connaître une augmentation écoutez
bien de 0 42% et d'autre part le smic
qui va lui aussi augmenté de 2,2 pour
cent soit une augmentation de 35 euros
brut avec ces chiffres la france est
devenue de las vegas du français moyen
qui ne va plus savoir quoi faire de tout
cet argent déversé sur lui par les fêtes
bruno le maire le grand argentier de
l'aubonne nationale et au rêve tout
éveillé tellement ces chiffres sont
ébouriffant de générosité deux promesses
de lendemains qui chantent et d'une fin
de mois qui pourrait se terminer le 30
et non plus le 10 comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui car c'est tout de même un
pactole de 1589 euros et 47 centimes
mensuel qui vous attend chers amis
smicards et la fin de l'année s'annonce
aussi très difficile avec de nombreuses
augmentations de toutes sortes pour les
français et des réformes à venir engagé
par le gouvernement lors nicolas qu'en
est il eh bien oui la situation pourrait
se compliquer d'ici la fin de l'année
pour le gouvernement qui cherche à
imposer au bulldozer une série de
réformes explosive ajoutons une épidémie
de hausse tarifaire qui vont faire très
mal aux français plus près de l'ariège
ruralité et des ronds points que du 55
rue du faubourg saint-honoré il faudra
compter sur la réforme d'assurance
chômage dont le tome départ est fixée au
1er octobre cette réforme très
controversée dont elisabeth bornes notre
minute du télétravail non non du travail
pardon estime que le système actuel est
trop généreux il n'incite pas des
centaines milliers de français enfiler
le bleu de chauffe elle qui aimait que
les métros partent à l'heure lorsqu'elle
était la patronne de la ratp veut aussi
que sa pointe massivement des
entreprises et que ça se travaille ça
moufter même 1500 balle mais c'était
sans compter sur le rapport alarmant de
l'unedic qui extime que le changement du
mode de calcul des allocations va
impacter près de 1 million 115 une
personne avec une baisse moyenne de 17%
de leurs allocations une paille on vous
dit une paille alors oui que certains se
contentent de la bienveillance de pôle
emploi c'est un fait mais la grande
majorité des chômeurs et ceux qui
arrivent tous les jours sur le marché la
précarité sont des victimes d'une
politique de l'emploi désastreuse
confrontés à la mondialisation aux deux
ping social européen aux nombreuses
délocalisations
il ya une situation économique
catastrophique malgré ce qu'on pense
bruno lemerle oracle bea de la macro ni
réjouit les ouvriers de bridgestone de
mbf den bosch ii inteva de knorr ou des
fonderies du poitou ne sont que les
victimes expiatoires du processus inique
de la mondialisation mené par qui par
emmanuel macron et ses prédécesseurs qui
ne jurent plus que par l'ubs et risation
notre société al cela il faut ajouter la
réforme des retraites qui obsède
emmanuel macron cette injonction
bruxelloise est marqué en gros en rouge
sur un post it collé sur le coin de son
ordi carnier que ces réformes font
partie des obligations européennes et
qu'elles sont dans le dip pour toucher
le che cause du plan de relance relève
de sacré numéro d'illusionniste
d'ailleurs le commissaire européen
thierry breton a appelé de ses voeux
cette réforme ce week-end sur une chaîne
concurrente mais tout cela n'a rien à
voir nous dit on on nous prend vraiment
pour des jambons mois mais a quand même
de quoi espérer un peu nicolas puisque
la situation normalement on devrait
s'améliorer sur le plan économique comme
nous dit bruno le maire et va suivre
aussi le pouvoir d'achat ben je ne fais
que ça mois espérait alors finissons
avec un brin d'optimisme chers amis la
hausse du tarif du gaz avait atteint des
niveaux historiques le 1er novembre avec
une augmentation de 12% en accélérant la
précarité deux centaines milliers de
foyers qui vont devoir brûler de la cage
est dans le salon cet hiver du côté des
carburants les tarifs s'envolent à cause
d'une grosse augmentation pour le baril
de brent est aujourd'hui les tarifs sont
plus élevés qu'au début de la crise et
gilet jaune et barbara pompili même
temps milite pour que les français
prennent le vélo pour aller bosser allez
demander à nos amis de la creuse de la
lozère s'ils ont envie d'aller bosser en
vélo en plein mois de janvier pas sûr
pas sûr qu'ils sautent de joie notons
aussi les craintes récentes de la grande
distribution sur une augmentation dans
les prochains mois des produits de
première nécessité et puis il ya les
français qui ont fait le choix de ne pas
se faire vacciner alors pour eux c'est
le jackpot la timbale le gros lot car le
tarif pourrait être de 43 euros pour un
dessert en laboratoire et ça pourrait
durer nous dit-on jusqu'à l'été prochain
vous me direz c'est toujours moins cher
qu'un plein donc il faudra choisir entre
le coton tige dans le nez ou aller
travailler les prochaines semaines vont
se sentir le soufre sociale et on va pas
beaucoup rigolé mais pendant ce temps on
peut essayer de faire comme des proches
qui disait je cite j'étais de ne pas
dire on comptera dick sur les idées que
je ne défends pas merci beaucoup nicolas
nicolas vidal qu'on retrouve tous les
jeudis matins pour l'édito politique
dans la matinale de rtl france merci